So now that we have defined
what a Markov chain is,
what can we do with it?
Well, we usually
build models in order
to predict some
phenomenon of interest.
In the case of a Markov
chain, there is randomness.
And so it is natural
to think about making
probabilistic predictions.
For example, going back again
to our checkout counter example,
you have arrived at 6:45 PM.
There are two
customers in a queue.
And you want to predict
the number of customers
in the queue at 7:00 PM.
Assuming time steps
are in seconds,
that corresponds to
900 times steps later.
There is no way to know exactly
where the system will be.
But you may be able to give
probabilistic prediction.
That is, to give the
probability for the system
to be in a given state
900 time steps later.
Our main purpose will be to
calculate such probabilities.
And notation will
be useful here.
Suppose that the Markov
chain of interest
starts in a given state, i, and
that it runs for n transitions.
Let us introduce the notation
rijn to represent the n step
transition probability
of ending in state j.
This is the initial state, i.
And this is the
definition, rij of n.
First note that these
are probabilities.
Given that you started
in i, after n steps,
you will end up in some
state with probability 1.
So the summation of all rij of
n for all possible states j,
will be 1.
And this is true for all
i, all initial state,
and for any time step n.
Also, because we have a
time invariant Markov chain,
rijn is also given
by this formula
here for any
possible value of s.
Going from here to
here, plus s, plus s.
In other words, if currently you
are in state i at time steps s,
and you're interested
in knowing what
is the probability of being
in state j at time n plus s,
which mean n steps
later, you will still
have the same expression-- rijn.
So how to calculate rijn.
For some particular
n, this is easy.
For example, for
rij of zero, that
means that there
are no transition,
it will be either 1 if i
equal j, and zero otherwise.
In one step, in other words,
when n equals 1, rij of 1
will be the
probability transition
given by the Markov chain.
And that is true
for all i and all j.
Now let us calculate rijn for
n greater than or equal to 2.
We are going to apply the total
probably theorem, and break up
the calculation of that
quantity by considering
the different ways that the
event of interest can happen.
Again, the event of interest
is to go from i, state i,
to state j in n times steps.
There are many ways for
that event to happen.
Let's group these many
different ways, as follows.
Let us consider the
first n minus 1 steps.
And group together
all possible ways
of going from i to a
state k, a given state k,
in n minus 1 steps.
And this wiggle path here
represent all possible ways
of doing that.
Using the definition
above, that probability
of going from i to
k in n minus 1 steps
will be rik of n minus 1.
Now assuming that you
ended up in state k in n
minus 1 transitions,
the probability
that you end up in state
j in the next transition
is simply the one-step
transition probability, pkj.
So altogether, the probability
of going from state
i to state j in n steps,
and in being in state k
after n minus 1 steps is
simply rik n minus 1 times pkj.
Note that state k can be
any of the finite number
of possible states
of our system.
In summary, all
such paths can be
represented by the
following diagram.
So again, from time
zero, you are in state i.
And you want to be
at time n in state j.
And you break down
all the possible ways
by first looking at what would
happen after step n minus 1.
You can be in state 1, state
k, all the way to state m.
We have calculated
these expression here.
This is what we have done here.
This is for state 1 and state m.
So the overall probability
of reaching node j
is obtained by an application of
the total probability theorem.
It gives the following formula.
So this is corresponding to
the total probability theorem.
Here, this is the calculation
that we have done here.
And we sum over all
possibilities for k.
Where did we use the Markov
property in this calculation?
Well, the key step
here was when we
said that this
probability here was pkj.
Going back to the
calculation that we had here,
this was in fact the probability
of being in state j at times n,
given you started in state i,
and you were in state n minus 1
in k.
And that probability being
equals to the probability of xn
equals j given the last time.
That is due to Markov.
And this is pkj.
This is a recursion in
the following sense.
Assume that you have
calculated rik n minus 1
for all possible values of i,
and all possible value of k.
And you have stored all these
values, m square of them.
For any pair, ij, you
can now calculate rijn
using that formula.
And you can do it in,
essentially m multiplication,
and m minus 1 additions.
That is, in a number of steps
or number of elementary steps
proportional to m.
You do this for all m square
pair of ij at the time step n.
And then you repeat for
n plus 1, et cetera.
So this is the essence
of the recursion.
Here is a variation that
is another recursion
for computing rij of n.
You start at i.
And suppose that in
the one time step,
you find yourself in state k.
The probability here is the
one-step transition, pik.
And then, given that
you are in state k, what
is the probability
that you will end up
in state j in n minus 1 step?
Will be, again,
looking at this formula
that we had here,
rkj of n minus 1.
Again, you have to consider
all possible values for k here.
And the application of the
total probability theorem
gives the following
alternative recursion.
rij of n, is the sum
for all k equals 1 to m
of pik times rkj of n minus 1.
These two recursions-- this one
and this one-- are different.
They are both valid,
and could be useful,
depending on the
specific questions
you may want to answer.
Finally note, that if the
initial state is itself random,
that is given by a random
distribution-- this
is the initial
distribution on the state,
than the state probability
distribution after n steps
will be given by this formula.
This is the state after n step.
It's simply that.
And this is, yet
again, an application
of the total
probability theorem.